Hi everybody! I'm Josh Welsh, President of
Film Independent on what feels like day 3927
of being cooped up at home, I could
not be more excited to be here with you
to share our nominations for the 2021 Film
Independent Spirit Awards. 2020 obviously
was hell on earth but one glorious lifeline
these past few months has been the ability to
watch so many great films and shows. This year's
spirit award nominees inspired us, connected us
and have been a source of urgently needed light
in some pretty dark times, so even though we're
all still stuck at home the time has arrived.
Let's come together and celebrate all the great
work of 2020! Three new things to share with
you about this year's Spirit Awards, first
we've introduced awards to recognize the best of
television that embodies the Independent Spirit,
the shows that we celebrate today possess the same
qualities original provocative subject matter,
uniqueness of vision and diversity that our film
nominations do. Second, at a time when the country
continues to undergo a serious reckoning with
racial justice Film Independent remains resolute
in our commitment to fighting for a film industry
that looks like the world we actually live in! So
when we talk about diversity and equity at
the Spirit Awards it's not an afterthought
or a side note but a fundamental value that
runs through our entire process. This year of
our nominated writers and directors 57 percent
are women and 48 percent are BIPOC and of our
nominating committee members who worked so hard to
reach today's nominations, 67 percent were women
and 63 percent were BIPOC, third and finally this
year the spirit awards will be broadcast on IFC,
not on the Saturday afternoon before the oscars,
but on the Thursday night before the oscars,
Thursday April 22nd 10 pm eastern 7 p.m pacific,
one more note about the Spirit Awards for
anyone who might be new to this. The winners of
the spirit awards are chosen by Film Independent
members, Film Independent there you go Film
Independent is an open access organization
that welcomes film lovers and filmmakers alike,
no matter who or where you are on planet earth,
if you care about great storytelling we want you
as a member. In order to vote this year please
join film independent by February the 11th, you'll
get screeners of the nominated films and shows but
most of all you will be part of the community who
decides who wins the Spirit Awards in 2021. We are
so grateful for our spirit award premier sponsor
IFC as well as Fiji water the official water of
the Spirit Awards, our sponsors make the program
possible, as well as our year-round activities,
so for that we're we are so grateful. We're also
honored to be partnering with the Association
of National Advertisers Seeher, the leading
global movement for gender equality and media
advertising marketing and entertainment
and AMC Networks to further celebrate
and act as a catalyst for accurate and meaningful
representation in storytelling. Finally I want to
thank the people who worked so hard to come up
with these nominations this year we had over 40
dedicated filmmakers and film lovers who spent
months on our Spirit Award nominating committees
they watched and discussed over 650 films and
series, fiction and non-fiction American and
International, that is a record by the way of
the number of submissions that we got this year
in order to arrive at today's nominations. With
that I will stop talking! I will go back to my
Fiji water, but before I just want to say I'm
so happy to introduce three amazing filmmakers
who will announce today's nominations. Spirit
Award winners Olivia Wilde and Barry Jenkins
and the one and only, Laverne Cox. With that
Olivia take it away! Thank you so much J osh!
It is such an honor to be here to help announce
the 2021 Film Independent Spirit Award nominees!
uh true to independent film, I did my own hair and
makeup I don't have any snacks um and the lighting
is a little iffy, but you know we get it, in the
independent film community we make it work we make
it work! And this year so many incredible movies
have come out and we get to celebrate them and I'm
just so honored to be here to help announce the
nominees, so i will get started! Best Screenplay;
the nominees are Bad Education, Minari, The
Half of It, Never Rarely Sometimes Always
and Promising Young Woman. The nominees in the
category of Best Cinematography; The Assistant,
Bull, Never Rarely Sometimes Always, Nomadland and
She Dies Tomorrow. Best Documentary, the nominees
are; Collective, Crip Camp, Dick Johnson is Dead,
The Mole Agent and Time. Best First Feature,
this one holds a very special place in my heart
because we were lucky enough to win this last year
for Booksmart and it was the greatest moment of my
career! And my chair fell over and I was paralyzed
with shock and didn't know what to do and it
was amazing! The nominees in the category of
Best First Feature are; I Carry You With Me, The
40-Year-Old Version, Miss Juneteenth, Nine Days
and Sound of Metal. The nominees in the category
of Best Supporting Male are; Colman Domingo from
Ma Rainey's Black Bottom, Orion Lee for
First Cow, Paul Raci for Sound of Metal,
Glynn Turman from Ma Rainey's Black
Bottom and Benedict Wong from Nine Days.
The nominees in the category of Best Male Lead;
Riz Ahmed Sound of Metal, Chadwick Boseman
for Ma Rainey's Black Bottom, Ardarsh Gourav The
White Tiger, Rob Morgan Bull, Steven Yuen Minari.
The nominees in the category of the John
Cassavetes Award; The killing of two lovers,
La Leyenda Negra, Lingua Franca, Residue and Saint
Frances. And I am so so excited to announce this
year's winner of the Robert Altman Award, which
is given to one film's director, casting director
and ensemble cast. And the winner this year
is; One Night in Miami Director Regina King,
Casting Director Kimberly R. Hardin and the
incredible ensemble cast Kingsley Ben-Adir,
Eli Goree, Aldis Hodge and Leslie Odom Jr., now to
announce the rest of these incredible nominees for
this amazing year in film I'm going to throw it
over to you Barry! Thank you Olivia, my name is
Barry Jenkins and this is Chauncey Wang Jenkins
and we're here to present some Spirit Award
nominees to you. The nominees in the category of
Best First Screenplay uh which I was not nominated
for are; The Assistant, Lapsis, Miss Juneteenth,
Palm Springs and Straight Up. Congratulations to
all those Best First Screenplay nominees, I
don't know what that feels like, because my
first screenplay was not nominated um I'm pretty
sure that's true. The nominees in the category
of Best Editing what are the nominees Chauncey?
The nominees in the category of Best editing are;
I Carry You With Me, The invisible Man, Never
Really Sometimes Always, Nomadland and Residue.
The nominees in the category of Best
International Film are; Bacurau, The Disciple,
Night of the Kings, Preparations to be Together
for an Unknown Period of Time, and Quo Vadis,
Aida? The nominees and the category
of Best supporting Female are Alexis
Chikaeze from Miss Juneteenth, Yeri Han for
Minari, Valerie Mahaffey for French Exit,
Talia Ryder from Never Rarely Sometimes
Always and Yuh-Jung Yoon for Minari. The
nominees in the category of Best female Lead are
Chauncey say; Nicole Beharie Miss Juneteenth,
Viola Davis Ma Rainey’s Black Bottom, Sidney
Flanigan Never Rarely Sometimes Always,
Frances McDormand Nomadland and Carey Mulligan
Promising Young Woman. The nominees in the
category of Best Director are Lee Isaac Chung
Minari, Emerald Fennell Promising Young Woman,
Eliza Hittman Never Rarely Sometimes Always, Kelly
Reichardt First Cow and Chloé Zhao Nomadlandand,
the nominees for Best Feature Film are;
First cow, Ma Rainey’s Black Bottom, Minari,
Never Rarely Sometimes Always and Nomadland. And
now from myself and Chauncey over to you Laverne.
Thank you so much Barry, I'm still waiting
on that invitation to work together
you know I'm serious I'll bring it for
you Barry! I'll bring it let's do it.
I'll start with the emerging filmmaker award
categories, each of these awards recognizes
emerging filmmakers who have not yet received the
appropriate recognition. The Truer Than Fiction
Award is presented to a talented director
of non-fiction features, the finalists are;
Cecilia Aldarondo, director of Landfall, Elegance
Bratton director of Pier Kids, Elizabeth Lo
director of Stray, the Someone To Watch Award
honors a talented filmmaker of singular vision
the finalists are; David Midell director
of The Killing of Kenneth Chamberlain,
Ekwa Mwangii director of Farewell Amor, Annie
Silverstein director of Bull, the Producers
Award which is given to an emerging producer who
despite highly limited resources demonstrates the
creativity tenacity and vision required to produce
quality independent films the finalists are;
Kara Durrett, Lucas Joaquin, Gerry Kim and
now to the inaugural television categories
the nominees for Best New Scripted Series are;
A Teacher, I May Destroy You, Little America,
Small Axe, Unorthodox. The nominees for
Best New Non-Scripted or Documentary series
are; Atlanta’s Missing and Murdered: The Lost
Children, City So Real, Immigration Nation,
Love Fraud, We're Here. The nominees for best male
performance in a new scripted series are; Adam Ali
Little America, Nicco Annan P-Valley,
Amit Rahav Unorthodox, Harold Torres
ZeroZeroZero, Conphidance Little America. The
nominees for Best Female Performance in a New
Scripted Series are; Elle Fanning The Great, Shira
Haas Unorthodox, Abby McEnany Work in Progress,
Maitreyi Ramakrishnan
Never Have I Ever,
Jordan Kristine Seamón We Are Who We Are, The best
ensemble in a New Scripted Series is awarded to;
I May Destroy You Ensemble Cast: Michaela Coel,
Paapa Essiedu, Weruche Opia, Stephen Wight.
Congratulations to all the nominees today and
remember only Film Independent members vote for
the winners of the Spirit Awards so to become a
member visit filmindependent.org and join today
and don't forget tune in on our new date and time
Thursday April 22nd at 10 pm eastern 7 pacific
only on IFC thank you Laverne and thank you Olivia
and Barry and Chauncey and luna thanks you too
uh congratulations to all of today's nominees
and remember only Film Independent members vote
for the winners of this Spirit Awards so
if you'd like to do that and i hope you do
please become a member of Film Independent just
visit filmindependent.org and you can figure it
out there don't forget tune in our new date and
time Thursday April the 22nd at 10 p.m eastern 7
p.m pacific on IFC with that thank you all so
much and uh look forward to seeing you soon!